>> NEIL: ALL RIGHT, ANOTHER BIG
COMPANY FROM SILICON VALLEY IS
SAYING GOOD-BYE TO SILICON
VALLEY.
NOT ENTIRELY, BUT HEWLETT
PACKARD ENTERPRISES IS GOING TO
MOVE A LOT OF THE OPERATIONS TO
HOUSTON, TEXAS.
THE MAYOR OF SAN JOSE HAS BEEN
DOING HIS BEST TO STOP THIS SORT
OF THING.
IT’S HAPPENING YET AGAIN.
MAYOR, GOOD TO HAVE YOU.
WHAT DO YOU MAKE OF THIS?
NOW, IT LOOKS LIKE READING
HEWLETT PACKARD’S COMMENTS ON
THIS, IT’S NOT ABANDONING YOUR
AREA, BUT IT’S CUTTING DOWN ITS
PRESENCE IN YOUR AREA.
DOES IT ALARM YOU?
>> WELL, CERTAINLY IT’S A WAKEUP
CALL FOR ALL OF US, NEIL.
AND THE GOOD NEWS IS HERE IN THE
CITY OF SAN JOSE, WE’RE ADDING
HUNDREDS OF EMPLOYEES BECAUSE
THEY’RE CONSOLIDATING OPERATIONS
HERE FROM SILICON VALLEY AND MY
CITY.
WE’RE SEEING HEADQUARTERS MOVE
BE.
THIS IS A STORY WE’VE SEEN
BEFORE.
THAT CERTAINLY FOR THE KIND OF
TALENT THAT YOU REALLY NEED TO
FIND IN SILICON VALLEY, THE
HIGHLY SPECIALIZED AROUND
ARTIFICIAL INTELLIGENCE OR
ENGINEERING OR SOFTWARE, YOU’LL
FIND IT IN SILICON VALLEY AND
THE FOLKS THAT WANT TO LOCATE
HERE.
BUT IF YOU’RE LOOKING TO EXPAND
OPERATIONS FOR ACCOUNTANTS OR
LAWYERS OR ADMINISTRATIVE
ASSISTANTS, YOU CAN DO THAT FOR
A LOT OF PLACES FOR A LOT LESS.
AND, WE HAVE TO DO MORE TO MAKE
THIS REGION AND THIS STATE MORE
AFFORDABLE.
>> NEIL: YOU’VE BEEN KIND OF --
YOU WERE RE-ELECTED IN 2018 WITH
MORE THAN 70, WHAT, 5% OF THE
VOTE AT THE TIME.
AND LARGELY BY TAKING ON, YOU
KNOW, UNIONS AND PENSION-FUNDED
ORGANIZATIONS WHERE YOU JUST
WANTED TO EASE BACK ON THOSE
OBLIGATIONS BECAUSE THEY’RE A
GOOD REASON WHY SAN JOSE AND
OTHER AREAS ACROSS THE COUNTRY
WITH SIMILAR ISSUES ARE SO
PRICEY AND ARE BEING PRICED OUT
AND HAVING COMPANIES MOVE.
BUT THAT APPARENTLY IS NOT
ENOUGH.
SO, WHAT DOES THE STATE HAVE TO
DO?
>> WELL, THE BIGGEST CHALLENGE,
I THINK WE ALL HAVE IS WITH
HOUSING COSTS.
IT’S HARD TO LIVE HERE.
COMPANIES HAVE TO PAY A LOT JUST
TO KEEP PEOPLE HERE.
THERE’S A LOT MORE WE NEED TO DO
TO RAMP UP PRODUCTION.
WE CAN CERTAINLY GET SOME OF THE
RED TAPE OUT OF THE WAY.
AND I APPRECIATE THE RECENT
EFFORTS OF THE GOVERNOR, FOR
EXAMPLE, TO BE ABLE TO -- FOR
EXAMPLE, WAGE ON THE AFFORDABLE
HOUSING WE NEED FOR HOMELESS
RESIDENTS THAT ENABLED US TO
BUILD THREE SEPARATE
DEVELOPMENTS IN FOUR MONTHS
RATHER THAN FOUR YEARS.
THOSE ARE THE THINGS WE NEED TO
DO.
MOSTLY JUST GETTING OUT OF THE
WAY.
WE NEED TO BE MORE INNOVATIVE IN
HOW WE’RE BUILDING HOUSES.
WE’RE USING DIFFERENT
TECHNOLOGIES, PREFAB AND MODULAR
HOUSING.
THAT ALLOWS THE LOCAL
BUREAUCRACIES TO BE NIMBLE, TO
PERMIT THOSE THINGS AND STILL
ALLOW THE INNOVATION.
HOUSING IS AT THE CORE OF IT.
IT’S A LOT GOING ON.
TAXES, REGULATION, A LOT OF
ISSUES WHERE I THINK WE NEED TO
BE COGNIZANT IN CALIFORNIA.
WE’VE BEEN TAKING IT FOR GRANTED
FOR TOO LONG THAT TECH EMPLOYERS
WANT TO BE HERE.
THAT WON’T HAPPEN FOREVER.
>> NEIL: DID YOU OFFER AN
ALTERNATIVE DEAL TO STOP HEWLETT
PACKARD FROM MAKING THIS MOVE?
WE’RE BUILDING THIS BIG FACILITY
IN HOUSTON, WE’RE GOING THERE.
>> I’VE BEEN CLEAR THAT WE DON’T
WANT TO OFFER COMPANIES DEALS OF
ANY KIND.
WHEN AMAZON WAS ANNOUNCING THE
CONTACTS AT THE MIDDLE OF THE
HEADQUARTERS, I WROTE AN OP-ED
SAYING, WE’RE NOT GOING TO GIVE
YOU MONEY.
I DON’T BELIEVE GIVING TAXPAYER
NOUN COMPANIES.
HP NEVER ASKED FOR IT.
THEY’VE BEEN ABOVE BOARD WITH
US.
I UNDERSTOOD WHY THEY WOULD BE
GOING TO HOUSTON.
THEY HAVE A LOT OF OPERATIONS
ALREADY THERE AND A LOT OF
EMPLOYEES.
BUT, FOR THOSE HEADQUARTERS
OPERATIONS, YOU DON’T NEED THE
TECHNICAL -- THEY CAN KEEP ALL
OF THAT HERE IN SILICON VALLEY
AND HIRE ELSEWHERE.
>> NEIL: YOU KNOW IT’S MORE THAN
JUST TAXES AND THE COST OF
LIVING.
I KNOW YOU ARE EVE APOLOGIZED
FOR THIS INCIDENT WHERE YOU
JOINED YOUR FAMILY FOR
THANKSGIVING.
IT WAS A LARGE GATHERING, LARGER
THAN YOU SUSPECTED.
BUT IT CAME AT A TIME WHEN A
NUMBER OF OTHER TOP POLITICIANS,
MOSTLY DEMOCRATS HATE TO SAY
THAT TO YOU, DID ONE THING AND
PRACTICED ANOTHER.
DO YOU THINK THAT PEOPLE LOOK AT
THAT, MAYOR, AND SAY, THE GUY IS
A HYPOCRITE?
>> SURE, I -- I RECOGNIZE FOLKS
THAT COME TO THOSE KINDS OF
CONCLUSIONINGS.
I MADE A MISTAKE AND I OWNED IT.
I SHOULD HAVE BEEN MORE ASTUTE
ABOUT THE SPECIFIC REGULATIONS.
I KNEW THERE WERE ADVISORIES AND
I SHOULD HAVE BEEN MORE ASTUTE
TO IT.
AND, YOU KNOW, I -- AS I LEARNED
IN THE MEDIA REPORTED THAT I WAS
AT HOME, WE IMMEDIATELY
DISCLOSED.
NO, I WAS AT MY PARENTS’ HOUSE
AND THAT’S HOW ALL OF THIS CAME
OUT.
SO, I -- GOING AND CERTAINLY --
WILL DO BETTER.
>> NEIL: WHEN YOU ADDED
RELATIVES’ HOUSE, THERE’S A BIG
CROWD HERE AND I’M THE MAYOR OF
SAN JOSE AND I’VE BEEN TELLING
MY CONSTITUENTS, KEEP IT SMALL,
KEEP IT LIMITED.
DID YOU THINK?
DID YOU --
>> I CAN’T CLAIM TO HAVE BEEN
SO -- THE REALITY IS, I HAVE A
BIG FAMILY, I’M ONE OF FIVE
KIDS, SO TYPICALLY THANKSGIVING
FOR US IS 25.
WE ACTUALLY HAD EIGHT ADULTS
DINING AT THE SAME TIME.
AND THE PROBLEM WAS UNDER THE
STATE RULES, YOU CAN ONLY HAVE
THREE HOUSE HOLDS.
AND SO WE HAD TOO MANY HOUSE
HOLDS THERE EVEN THOUGH ALL OF
US, MANY OF US HAD BEEN DINING
TOGETHER EVERY WEEK.
THE RULES HAVE CHANGED,
OBVIOUSLY, WE’VE GONE IN TO
DEEPER INTO THE -- THE
CHALLENGING PERIOD OF HIGH
INFECTION SPREAD.
AND I SHOULD HAVE KNOWN BETTER.
I SHOULD HAVE DONE BETTER.
>> NEIL: UNLIKE A LOT OF
POLITICIANS THAT DID THE SAME
THING, YOU GOT AHEAD OF IT AND
APOLOGIZED FOR IT.
SO, IF MORE DID, MAYBE IT WOULD
BE EASIER TO MOVE ON.